welcome back to on base with Mookie
Betts we are here in Cincy with my boy
hunter green what's going on bro
you got talking to the mic you know I
found my phone nothing much man I'm
chilling yeah hey man
um when I first seen you
them Shades stood out like where you get
those he's a Louis V uh they're called
the millionaires okay I like them
they're my favorite I lost a pair I
think last year I had to go back and get
another pair I think these are the best
ones too those are those are hard
appreciate it I like those I just had to
give you you know give you your flower
you know what I'm saying so
Hunter
you're the fourth fastest pitcher to 250
strikeouts did you know that yes
somebody told me that the other day I
never looked stuff up but I don't really
pay too much attention to that stuff but
one of our like reporters reminded me of
that the other day so you don't like
keep up with like your your numbers as
you're going out through the season I
try not to I mean like I mean it's the
thing you know like you know you see
where you are you see your numbers like
everywhere they'll be on TV they'll be
like right they're constantly in your
face so trying to keep the things that
are most important just the process you
know okay okay so and then you know that
you have the most hundred mile per hour
pitches in the game and you broke your
own record so you're just out here
breaking it over
the top three okay so so you knew how
what's it like throwing 100 miles per
hour like because nobody I mean I guess
a lot of people do it now but like not
as many times as as you obviously so
what is it like throwing 100 miles yeah
uh I mean I've been throwing that hard
since like my junior year high school so
I had 102 when I was a junior in high
school okay let's go back before that
like what what is this just what are you
eating straight from this is straight
from God like man just said Hunter
you're gonna throw a hundred from a rep
here it is yeah I'm saying is that was
that kind of man man I I mean obviously
like having a good throwing program I
feel like I learned that pretty early on
having the right people like around me
that knew enough about the body
uh Alan Jager being one of them uh you
know the J Bands yeah so oh yeah yeah I
knew him when I was seven went to his
first camp
uh and just like started to understand
okay like what's a good throwing program
obviously seven years old I'm not long
tossing right but like getting familiar
with like what a good solid Thorn
program looks like yeah
um so I got that early on and then from
there like just continuing to learn more
about my body uh doing yoga all that
stuff like coming together so you wake
up and you you have to short shorts too
when you go to yoga no I don't do the
shorts I got to work tights tights under
I don't do the the chubs I don't like
the chips
okay so tell me tell me about like a
routine you have you know to warm that
bad boy up because I'm saying you can't
just you that's got to get hot before
you start throwing a honey no I don't I
didn't fight I try not to do too much uh
I mean I'm also 23 man so like right
knowing that I'm young you know I can
you know pretty much get out of bed and
still feel pretty good
um but yeah there's a whole routine you
know getting to the field early enough
before I can in the Jacuzzi
or the hot tub go into the sauna loosen
up not being there too long though you
know I don't get tired and let it drain
me and stuff so I'll do that get a good
stretch from from our trainers
um have a little bit of quiet time you
know listen to some music what kind of
music you listen to well leading up to
right before I go out is pretty much r b
i love r b and then I'll put some
hip-hop on it and go from there then you
get the cracking before you get on the
field r b a little too I just like to
ease into it and then pick up as I go so
y'all's y'all's pitching songs do you
interchange that or is that just one I
just got one right now I I chose Rich
Flex uh you know by Drake yeah because
I'm number 21 so I thought it'd be dope
it came on I played it for like one game
and it was terrible oh wow yeah like the
timing didn't work you know the time is
going to be right it's going to be it's
like a solid two to two and a half
minutes where it's like okay this is the
perfect part of the song and like the
the beginning fire and then the rest of
the song like nothing I don't like 21's
part oh so like so you were just you
were you were off on it yeah I had to
bang it so I have a Yay Area Now by u40
so so why don't you why don't why
wouldn't y'all switch
every start
is it like a is it like a I think it's
just too much it's too much yeah four
days you're doing nothing I know you've
got plenty of time to come up with
another song
is it superstitious no it's just I don't
know man I just haven't put like that
much energy into it but I should maybe
I'll I'll think about that now so just
something to think about it you know at
least I mean I I got the best one for
sure okay all right well some of our
other guys got some um
well I mean you know I don't know you
need to help them out you help them out
so okay as we keep going we're I got a
game called on base and off base
with your in or out so tell me about
this on base or off base a skyrosa
you know what that is is that a drink no
sounds like the same thing but it's not
it's food you a foodie so Scott Rosie is
the Skyline Chili
oh wow oh with the pizza with the pizza
LaRosa's Pizza yeah man I didn't know
that was a thing they saw this at the
Ballpark a guy there you go right there
crushing it oh
man I'd have to like starve myself for
maybe a couple days before I'm
completely off on that
so you know to be honest like Skyline
Chili really isn't that bad I don't
think I've had I've had LaRosa's Pizza
I might have had LaRosa's pizza but
skyline's not too bad man it's it's got
a little like weird cinnamon like hint
to it in the chili
but like the fresh shredded cheddar
cheese on top with the coneys like the
hot dogs yeah they're actually not too
bad I gotta sit here and convince
everybody man because like the whole
concept the concept like it ain't good
okay all right it is good it tastes good
it tastes good yeah I promise it tastes
good okay so what about this
Jimmy Butler in the heat do you think
there he'll be able to win his ring oh
for sure uh you're you're on you know I
don't I don't watch basketball too much
I actually went to game seven in Boston
we were just there yeah tell me about
that that was the Indy and I went I had
some pretty good seats couldn't get
Courtside but we were on the floor so
close
those those seats were probably super
expensive crazy yeah we got a good deal
but then it was
uh the atmosphere was dope though like
Joey was there Rado was there uh will
Benson who just got to us was there
Alexis Diaz our closer we had a good
group of guys there we all went and just
and that I don't think that was a good
game though was it no they got they kind
of got smacked yeah it was crazy because
people were leaving like 10 minutes left
in the fourth I'm like geez yeah they're
like let's go Patriots on the way out I
was like jeez all right so what about
listening to the album on
um shuffle for the first time like the
first time we listened to the album you
put it on shuffle do you do that or are
you a straight guy no I go from the top
to the all right so you're off base on
that yeah I'm off base off base off base
yeah it's gotta be from in order what
about uh you taking your gaming setup on
the road you game no I don't man I like
playing video games
I know you're a big gamer though huh I'm
a pretty big gamer yeah yeah I never got
into it too so what do you I got like
three games GTA okay everybody's got to
have GTA yep right yeah everybody's good
Forza I love racing games yesterday yeah
and what's my third one in the show
those are those do you play with
yourself on the show I do yeah I mean
that's cool though I'm not even tripping
I'm not even sure I would too you know
what I'm saying I don't really play
what's your game what's your what's your
favorite it's called Apex Legends oh
Apex you've heard of Apex yeah I'm I'm
all in on that I'm I'm completely on
base on that that's the only game I play
I I don't have a whole lot of time to
play other games to really invest my
brain energy in other games so
um I just do that and uh I've actually
made a lot of friends you do like the
streaming and stuff yeah and like the
people I I've they come to games yeah
people just
will be online tell them they're coming
to games tomorrow or a great great game
yesterday so it's super cool and then
that now those aren't my friends but I
mean those are just people that I run
into all the time at games and then I
have
um gotten some friends just from being
on there so it's super super if you
maybe you should think about streaming
yeah I know a couple of people that do I
know I think giolito does it too like
he's pretty big on the show on Twitch
and so I don't I don't know if it's the
show but but yeah think about it so what
about um
on base off base
Joe Burrows haircut
I haven't seen his new haircut you
haven't seen it no that looks the same
as as it always does you guys have
another picture without the headband we
may not I don't know I just know y'all
don't y'all go to the same Barber
oh you do go to the same Harbor yeah so
he I just how do you know that yeah yeah
so so
I got to be on darn that his name is
Darnell shout out Darnell Darnell he's
nice with the Clippers though yeah he he
do he looked like he got you got you
right Darnell we just got to get my boy
Joe right you know what I'm saying just
fade in fade him up too high of a fade
that's why he got the headband off yeah
I can't really tell but you know go
ahead and get him right though I'm gonna
be blacklisted from a Bengals game now
all right so bro going back to to early
Hunter let's go to the young Hunter you
were a super hype he was he was LeBron
coming out he was on all the covers of
magazines I mean you probably had Scouts
everywhere right like you couldn't you
were famous young
Embrace that
all right yeah yeah
there it is baby face yeah so so how is
that man like that's that's a lot
because you have what age were you there
I was 17 17. I was a senior here you
know what I'm saying and and you're
LeBron like how was that uh it was it
was crazy uh you know being 17 I think
I'm the first black high school baseball
player on the cover of Sports
Illustrated so that was like my favorite
history piece on this Sports Illustrated
cover
um knowing what that means that the
representation
um you know how much substance and
you know there was in that article it
wasn't just being a baseball player but
at the time
um I you know was coming kind of out of
middle school going into high school I
was speaking Korean don't ask me to say
anything okay now I played the violin a
little bit so like all of that was in
there I still paint and draw to this day
it's kind of like my little Escape that
I do so like all of that was put in that
that article and it was cool just to see
like the holistic part of of me at that
age
um was really special they actually did
another uh cover in Sports Illustrated
but the kids edition with all my
paintings on the front so that was cool
too to get that that feature but you've
been paying for a long time yeah so like
my first introduction into into art my
mom taught me calligraphy when I was
like maybe 10 or 11 years old she got me
like a whole set and that's when I like
you know started to really like work on
my penmanship and that was my first
introduction to Art and then since then
like I was sketch I got my own
Sketchbook I'll bring on the road yeah
okay yeah like do a lot of canvas work
on big canvases so just stuff like that
I did Art in high school I took APR I
loved my art teacher so like
he was great man so I just stuck with it
all the way up until now and you know
everybody's got their own little thing
yeah you you gonna make some paintings
and sell them all right man people might
as well people have asked me to right
now it's still kind of like that sacred
time for me to just like get away from
the game and certain stuff so I haven't
really opened it up too much but I got a
pretty good idea on bringing something
to the city yeah that'd be super cool
man yeah like you could stream just put
a camera up people will watch that oh
yeah you know what I'm saying I don't
watch I think that's super cool so
people have said that'd be a long live
stream though but hey I think what else
we're doing yeah so so I got four days
exactly
going back so back in high school like
when you went to school and you had then
everybody knew you right
how was that like going being in class
like did you ever feel like that was far
that was cool yeah but like I wasn't I
didn't go to a bunch of parties and
stuff like I was so locked in yeah
like changing classes with everybody
like oh Hunter hey Hunter like did you
get all that uh a little bit Yeah Yeah
but I feel like people
yeah
I didn't say anything at the time but in
my head I was like
okay okay but uh yeah I mean it it was
crazy man but like it was cool like that
day that it released I went out to uh I
think it was like a daily newsstand uh
kind of like right down the street from
my high school that I went to and they
had all my magazines there like on the
shelves and me and my boy just went
right after our baseball practice after
school and just like cleared the whole
entire shelf it was done so like I just
remember that that memory was really
cool and being able to see it in like
grocery stores and stuff uh just special
it's super cool yeah so then you got you
were supposed to go number one overall
ended up going number two to Cincy did
you feel a certain way with it when you
went two instead of one
I mean at the time I think knowing the
class and like all the the rumors and
stuff and there are you as you know just
rumors you never know what a team really
needs or right you know you think that
just because the best players are on the
draft are going to go 1-1 but if
somebody don't need a pitcher and they
need someone else you ain't getting
picked or whatever it is so I didn't
really understand that part of the game
that the business side of that
um but my boy ended up getting picked
1-1 Royce Lewis with the twins yeah we
grew up playing together he's from
Southern California yes we played like
we did area codes together I think we
did like the perfect game thing together
that that All-American Game
we did quite a few events together and
played each other in high school and
stuff so a really good dude man he's
kind of had a tough go but he's back in
the big leagues which is cool to see
yeah no he and he's playing well too
yeah yeah he's playing well so you uh
yeah you're from up the street
I forgot about that you are from up the
street so you were you a Dodgers fan
growing up yes big Dodgers fan it's not
like a huge Dodger fan but enough of a
fan yeah that was my team who who was
your player growing who's your guy
Raphael for call
ing what I'd be saying like it was like
what Raphael for call yeah like going to
to the game sitting Third Base side
watching him go on the five six jump up
through yeah it's fire so you used to go
to games all the time a good amount of
games yeah in traffic man I mean it's
just like it's so it's brutal huh it's
horrible so were you like I'm gonna play
for the Dodgers one day uh yeah I mean I
think any kid growing up like I could
you you just in the mirror you were you
had to dodge across your chest and you
was ready man you know it's funny I when
when my parents like pull
photos up when I'm younger when I was
younger I don't have like any Dodgers
gear like merch or anything oh it's kind
of interesting like I had a lot of
Stanford stuff I guess I wanted to go to
Stanford so I had a bunch of Stanford
shirts and sweatshirts but I never
really had like any Dodgers so which was
kind of weird well you just went to
games you enjoyed the game like you said
you were like a a fan of crazy but you
just enjoyed Dodgers Crush Dodger Dogs
Crush Dodge never had one maybe I should
think about it so you got a lot of M's
when you signed seven
right
um what was it like what was the first
thing you bought when you got that
oh man because you're 18 at this point I
think I bought some like M M's or
something no yeah stop
okay it was like some candy no seriously
what was your first big purchase big
purchase
uh I got my mama car oh nice okay
um nothing for you though nope nope I uh
man I actually I moved to Vegas my first
two years I broke my signing bonus up
for the two years I moved to Vegas zero
percent state tax yep so I lived there
for two years I was only 17 years old
but I couldn't do anything I was just
yeah oh I lived on the Strip it was only
17 when you signed up 17. on this trip
in Vegas yep I would just go work out
come back to my place and chill and that
was it that's yeah you didn't do nothing
didn't do nothing
the people that stayed in my place the
it was I could have gone to a lot of
trouble there but you didn't you had
some good people around you nobody was
around everybody was in LA but but yes
my parents raised me the right way so
good so then you you you missed two uh
Seasons right yeah you were hurt one
year TJ TJ 19 and then in 20
just did like the the old side so what
did you do yeah the whole year you just
did the outside yeah but I went out
there late I think I missed like the
first month of the old side I was still
training back in LA
and then went out there for like the
last month month and a half of the the
year I guess the old site yeah and so
what was it like missing two years of
because my league ball like I remember
for me
it was a grind
but that's where you meet so many people
and you you learn who you are because
you're on the road by yourself or with a
roommate sure you know you don't have
your girl with you your family is not
with you
you know I I really got to
know who mookie was you know what I'm
saying and so
like how was it for you since you you
know you kind of you missed two years
you really didn't get that opportunity
the the toughest part for me was
building the workload as a starting
pitcher coming out of high school I was
a shortstop like all four years of high
school I pitched you have to pull this
test it but I think I pitched like maybe
50 Innings all four years of high school
oh so like I never had the workload of a
starting pitcher coming out of college
you know or a High School pitcher that
was a PO After High School I played
shortstop and I happened to pitch so
like I never built that workload because
I didn't go to college so I wasn't
throwing the 120 innings for three years
or whatever
I didn't do that and then through the
minor leagues missing those two years
I never got past the most Innings I
threw in one season was I was 69 Innings
uh so you didn't even yeah so I never I
think I threw a total of 180 Innings or
something in the minor leagues yep total
so so so that's how Kobe was though
yeah but it's like man I would have I
kind of would have wished I they held me
like for an extra year to be honest with
you so I can build that you know because
like having to figure that out in the
big leagues is like how was that was
that hard to do yeah I'm still trying to
figure it out oh you're still trying
yeah I'm still trying to get that
workload and build and
um and all of that man I mean a lot of
kids you know going through High School
youth ball being mostly pitchers you
know they learn
won the workload but two like they learn
pitches they learn change up and stuff
like that I had to learn that stuff kind
of on the Fly because you you're just an
athlete that pitched correct your your
mindset wasn't in yeah like pitch
philosophy and like attacking it like I
never I just went and I threw hard so I
got away with it you know and and just
went with that and you know obviously
like I didn't rely just on my
athleticism I knew that I'd have to
figure certain things out
but it was so comfortable because I was
able to get away with it until getting
really to like
AAA double A I still got away with it a
little bit there's more prospects as you
know double A and then AAA you know you
have more guys that are coming from the
big leagues down so more experience so
like that was like the first time I was
like man I'm gonna have to throw
you know other than just throwing 100
plus I got to be able to move you know
move you guys change like all that stuff
I started to figure that out really in
like AAA so okay so you know it's late
that's really late and then now you see
you're still learning it now so when you
when you feel good right you're on the
bump you feel good I got my stuff today
and you're throwing 100 every pitch what
is it like when you face someone like
Arias who's hitting 400 you know what
I'm saying like
this is like I got to be careful or is
he like nah this I got my stuff today
you know because it there's there there
is that competitive thing where like
this guy is really good you know no
matter what I throw today he's gonna hit
it or no matter what he throws today
we're gonna be out you know what I'm
saying he's dot in the corner to be
honest with you like he means he's going
off I still haven't faced him yet we
played Mike oh okay okay so I mean pick
a guy yeah he's going off you know yeah
um to be honest with you man when I feel
like my best when my stuff is there
I truly believe that nobody's gonna
right nobody's good that's a great
mindset that like
that's just truly what I believe because
I've seen I've faced good enough lineups
early on already where it's like when I
feel good and what my stuff is on and
I'm able to locate it when I want where
I want it no one it's gonna be a good
day but when I feel a little off or you
know I'm not obviously I'm not
commanding as much as I'd like to
I gotta be a lot smarter you know and
yes the best pitches in the game but
it's also the best hitters you know so
having to make those adjustments
um but I think it's so it's always like
a respect thing but it's not a fear
thing right no no I'm not saying yeah
okay yeah that's I'm just saying that's
like yeah that's the mindset like yeah
like Arias and Acuna man whoever the
best Sitters in the game or whatever
right now but at the end of the day I
still have the upper hand if I'm able to
locate right you know and thought when
and where I want to throw it so and and
then what's it like
because I can give a hitters perspective
like when we don't have when I don't
feel good today it's like all right well
you know I'm just gonna go compete
like I've hit my whole life you know
what I'm saying I'm just gonna go
compete try and figure it out as I go
because some days you don't feel good a
lot of days you don't feel good I mean
we're humans right and so when you have
that start when you don't feel good like
what is it that you do because for me
like I said it's just like I'm just
gonna go compete whatever you know you
know I'm saying I still have to hit a
mistake you know no matter what I could
feel terrible in BP or terrible in the
cage and I can go four for four I
remember I had the worst VP I've ever
had and I had for the cycle you know
what I'm saying so same thing with
bullpens okay they will have a terrible
Bullpen and they'll go out there and
have a great game like I think you know
it's all a mindset yeah is it hard to
switch their mindset because you know
like you know like okay I'm Miss hitting
every ball or I'm missing every spot
like is it it's just it you have to kind
of trick yourself I think it was harder
last year
with not having enough experience and
even though I'm still in my second year
I feel like I have enough of a sample
size of pool from last year to be like
okay I've had this day before this is
not new
how do I tap into this now oh okay this
is what I did last time okay this was my
mindset okay this is this was my
preparation before going out to throw
before the game or checking myself after
the bull black man that was a terrible
Bullpen but I do feel good I'm just you
know I'm yanking a little bit too much
because I feel too good to where I'm a
little too explosive you know or
whatever it is and just being able to
check yourself and then using the
warm-up pitches before the ending starts
you know to lock yourself back together
like that as you know that comes with
experience yeah just like but being like
tuned in enough to know that you know
I'm terrible at Target it's all right
it's cyber because I remember Cece Cece
would go
to the bullpen you know you guys go out
early go to the bullpen throw probably
10 to 12 pitches and then he was walking
in and I'm like you know how well you're
not even really warm he's like man look
experience no matter how good or bad I
do out there I'm just warming my arm up
you know what I'm saying because the
game is going to be the game but to your
point he had experience with it so he
already knew what it was so you so
growing up you had a really good you had
really good people around you obviously
had good parents and you you were in
this the youth program at seven years
old how was that you're playing with a
in Compton especially so you're around
us yep you know how was that being
around us at seven years old because
when I was seven years old I wasn't
you know what I'm saying that it just
wasn't I I'm from Nashville I didn't
have the Compton like that you know what
I'm saying so how was that
man uh being able to go to the Youth
Academy that being the first Youth
Academy started by the Dodgers and the
angels uh was super special I dealt with
a lot of racial issues at the league
that I was a part of prior to going to
the Youth Academy
so I didn't get any playing time really
um I would hear a lot of racial you know
slurs or you know uh stuff that's
experienced by you know a lot of kids
unfortunately but uh my my dad my
parents you know were locked in enough
to
put me into another position and know
that okay the Youth Academy is a place
that will welcome my son I will want to
see my son do well we'll invest the time
they had some amazing coaches that were
already there current players and uh
ex-players and then guys that were just
about to get drafted so when I started
at the Academy
uh Anthony goes
Aaron Hicks Dom Smith
JP Crawford
uh and a few other guys but those are
the four that I can name uh where
they're about to get drafted so oh wow
like being behind them watching JP take
ground balls Dom hitting Aaron hitting
and I think Anthony and Aaron were still
like pitching because they're really
pitchers coming out because they were
throwing like a hundred I think they
were the best like pitching prospects
coming out of high school uh so like
seeing those guys you know every day
going to the academy which mind you was
like an hour and a half drive for me
every time going out it's because it's
you know Compton Long Beach out that way
yeah having to deal with that and uh but
man it was a blessing because I was
exposed to not just our people but the
Latin Community the Asian community and
being able to see all of that see all of
us come together and play the same Sport
and you know eat lunch together after
you know days of practice it was just it
was really dope to look back and see
that and I've done a lot of work at the
academies uh specifically that one I've
done a couple camps there and it's all
love to this day I mean I still talk to
all those guys all the coaches and uh
just just a blessing man to be able to
for my parents to put me in that
position yeah I was gonna say shout out
to our parents because you know my my
mom and dad always gave me
the best opportunities and everything
right and so everything I got I made the
best from being in the best opportunity
my I was around the best coaches around
the best players I had to play up you
know just to get better competition and
stuff like that and so you know shout
out to our parents for for giving us
that uh that uh that opportunity I love
you guys
yeah like learning how to sit my pops
taught me how to sit playing up I sat on
a team like just dealing with that
adversity like okay like you might not
be the best player on the team every
time
you got to sit today you got to learn
it's like life lessons you know what I'm
saying that we would always have to use
so go going forward now you just signed
a little six year deal so shout out
congrats shout out to hunter green for
those what made you want what made you
want to sign here though like what was
it they hear yeah man
um I think I saw just the seeing the
guys coming through the minor leagues
like you guys saw Ellie last night like
being able to see dudes like that McLean
that just came up with the shorts yeah
shortstop
um I mean we got a couple other dudes uh
incarnacios strand that's in AAA
yeah man we got we got a good group of
players coming up that really exciting
to watch so like seeing that yeah right
yeah ground up I think that was 112 he
grounded out 109 yesterday I'm like what
well it's funny because I think of like
O'Neill Cruz that dude everything he
touches is like 110 plus yeah you know
and like same build I didn't think that
ball was that high and then I went back
oh no bro he's like Tony is six seven
you know he threw a good pitch yeah it
was a good pitch
I thought it was a little too middle in
real time when I was watching and then I
went inside from that angle I'm like oh
that was up up yeah boom and you know so
so you believed in in what we had come
well what you had coming yeah yep so
that
um already man I've done so much I feel
like in this community from when I was
drafted I've done work at the Academy
here uh the Reds Community Fund just
doing stuff throughout the city uh
speaking at high schools like I already
felt like I was pretty embedded within
the community here early on from when I
was drafted and then just going through
you know the minor leagues and coming
through the city for like Red's Fest we
have like our Fan Fest we do in the in
December here uh
you know I already felt like I was
pretty well connected within the
community and knowing that you know I'll
still be I think 20 I'll be 29 at the
end of the career before agency that's
still a good idea yeah yeah knowing that
you know I was able to get some extra
money before that and having another
bite at the Apple like all of that stuff
um but really like the excitement of
bringing winning back to Cincy like
maybe we had such a great history here
yeah it was a good it was a good crowd
yesterday too yeah it was it wasn't bad
I mean like for being in Cincy they want
to see Ellie you know say I'm sure when
you pitch they come so like giving back
to the community is super huge for you
what I'm seeing like because you know
you want to be in Cincy and bring
winning back here so what is it what is
it that you feel that you could do for
the the younger kids especially
African-American but all younger kids
yeah to uh to grow the game or to grow
your brand or not even your brand the
baseball brand or or whatever you want
to say in that vein yeah I think the
most important thing and you know you
can attest to this is is being able to
is being accessible to the kids like
kids knowing that okay
mookie might have the same kind of
upbringing as I did or you know he oh
man he he deals with those struggles too
like even now like stuff like that and
and being able to humanize yourself uh
two kids by just going to talk to him
yeah yeah or just like yeah meeting them
and like having the one-on-one
interaction then being able to like Dap
You Up or like just that interaction man
I think goes so far you know because
when I was younger watching guys on TV
you see all the stars and you see the
lights the cameras and it's like Is that
real like can I attain that like is this
is this even a real person but if you
can have that interaction sit down you
know maybe it's a little q a or whatever
the you know the event is that you do
being able to have that that human
element you know and be able to relate
to the kids I think is really important
so anytime I have a chance to connect
with some kids or you know they'll be
like a group out in center field during
BP you know being able to go over and
just say what's up or sign form or you
know answer some questions I think that
goes a long way so do you go back home
in the off season or do you or do you
kind of hang around you kind of do both
yeah so I actually just got a place in
Arizona last year or after the season so
that's where my residency is that's
where I live but because it's so close
to L.A let's do go home yeah my family
so when you go home do you go to the
Youth Academy or do you do things while
you're at home no I'm like boozy now man
I go to UCLA uh you boozy now that's all
right no that comes with it that comes
man I haven't been to the academy in the
off season other than like my camps yep
but yeah I'll go to uc's just a lot
closer and that's where I was committed
so like
Her Savage is a great pitching coach so
I'll still talk to him about some stuff
but do you help those guys as well like
talk to or not help but like talk to
those guys
like a mentality though I feel like when
I help younger people it's a lot of his
mentality because it's hard to really
help physical yeah but it's weird
because I still feel like I'm too close
in age like I feel like I'm stunning
them like if I'm like tell them
something I feel like I'm like like
especially last year 22 like 21 going
into like AAA and so like it's too close
in age so I felt kind of weird like some
guys would ask me some stuff but I would
feel weird like giving them advice
because it's like like
we're almost the same age yeah like we
really are so like you're 100 Green in
the big leagues and I get it it is weird
but they would love to hear from you
yeah and you know what I'm saying like
year period a lot of times the best
teaching comes from your peers someone
closer someone closer like a lot of
hitting coaches I've had some really
good hitting coaches
and like right now I feel like my my
hitting coaches
if he's not the best in the Middle East
he's at least top three in the big
leagues yeah but my main hitting coach
is Really JD you know what I'm saying
like and he's closer in my age and not
that our hitting coach is old but right
he's just
I say that to say maybe for you you know
you give them one or two little things
and see because you're definitely not
selling you're 100 green bro they're
gonna they're gonna be like man I'm man
I'm just as old as you man no they could
give me yeah but
I'm gonna think about this conversation
and be like man mookie said that I
should say something yeah and say
something say something they ain't they
not throwing I don't even know how many
100 mile per hour pitches you've thrown
in the big leagues yeah you know what
I'm saying they're not taking the ball
until you guys do that you're gonna
listen to me no I don't just don't do it
that way but I say that to say like
you're 100 green dog they would love to
listen to you yeah they would love so so
yeah that's where I'm at in there I'll
I'll go if I go back I'll go to UCLA and
okay and so did you have a good
relationship with Joey Votto tell me
about Joey Votto because I don't really
know about it I get on base and I talk
to them
and I'm like
yeah like Joey where did you even think
of that dog man he's um one he's he's an
outstanding teammate
um someone that you know you'd want him
you know as a teammate in the clubhouse
um you know we don't have
man we don't really have like a lot of
vests we have will and we have Joey
right now and Joey's obviously in AAA
rehab and trying to get back but he's
been popping in and out up here just
because Louisville's so close for AAA
and so that's been nice to still have
him here as much as he can be but
um super intellectual dude like really
really smart
um is really good at chess so he's just
like it's how his mind works I feel like
he's like constantly like he's always
thinking about something uh but yeah he
does he saying some some silly stuff
he'd be saying some silly stuff so I got
a game for us
it's called Vado ornado
all right
I feel like it's gonna get me in trouble
whatever it is what it is so
um if it's if you think it's something
Joe evado said
bottle okay not natto okay are these
from your
your uh on base combos or these are just
like uh no this is this is something
random yes
I legitimately would like to drive a
yellow bus when I'm older I want you to
be a crossing guard or drive a yellow
bus yeah that's about it you know he did
he did like a whole segment on this do
you know but I didn't hear about this I
think he drove to Louisville
and just pulled up
so he's a really good teammate though
he's really good at baseball yeah but
he's just like he does some he does dope
stuff like he just like he'll wear like
he'll wear like Vans just like a regular
tea and like some like loose pants he
looked homeless but so Joey bottle is
the definition of keep everybody
guessing like yes that's man that's a
great way to put it that's joking about
me that's joking that that tells me a
lot that tells me everything I need to
know yeah so next time I see Joey
don't know what to expect yeah just just
go with an open mind yeah whatever
yeah
okay so what about this ninety percent
of this game if is half mental
that sounds like something Joey would
say it probably is it he did he didn't
say that heavy thinking right he'll say
something he'll be like yeah it'd be
like
what
Auto
um what about this I didn't know I got
hurt I just thought I stunk
say it one more time I didn't know I got
like stunk stunk okay yeah not like
funky sting like wasn't good stink
uh I'll go with natto yep he said it he
said he said I didn't know I got it how
you didn't know you did how you didn't
know you got hurt
stunt I just thought I'm stuck okay so
what about this
Aqua remember a sports writer asking me
for a quote and I didn't know what a
quote was
I just thought it was some type of soft
drink
yeah like he would say something like
that no you're so bad at this game you
but that's what I'm saying though like
you never know
you guessed it yeah exactly I'm guessing
right now but like you would say
something like that no okay Joe demise
all right so what about this I just want
I just want the games to be faster most
restaurants close around 9 10 p.m it's
hard to make a reservation and make it
if you're playing three and a half
playing a three and a half hour game see
like he would say that but he can get he
has so many connections like he can keep
restaurants open yeah he did say it and
he can't he can keep so I don't know why
yeah but it's Joey Votto he may just not
or you might just bang it and just go
back to the crib
dang so so and just cook he had and he
where is he from again he's from he's
from Toronto Toronto from the toe from
the toe it's a great City so one last
one
I was yelling to my teammates I don't
want to hit anymore somebody ended and I
meant it not because I didn't get hits
but because I wanted to go get some
fried chicken
that's not a
don't tell me he said that bro Joey
Votto said no no he didn't yeah I don't
know when he said it
like I've had a couple interactions with
him at first base
and I just I wasn't sure I loved him
though like you know what I'm saying I
wanted to keep getting them first yeah
and uh and uh and talk to him but I
wasn't uh I didn't know what to expect
and you know sometimes I met him I
remember meeting him in Triple A what
was your first experience like when you
met him
man what was her first
I can't remember what our first
encounter was it was probably when I
think it was when I was drafted in 17
and like probably just said spring
training or something in the weight room
and I was just like super quiet and he
was just like hey man like
whatever I think that was like our first
so first do you do you have any other
people like on other I guess the Bengals
what other sports are here in Cincy
that's it's the Bengals and it's the FC
team I want to go see some soccer do you
do you do you know any of those guys I
don't know anybody with the FC team I've
been to any games so I haven't like
interacted with the team but I've met
quite a few Bengals guys I've been to I
think just two games
uh man we have them come like all the
time to the stadium I actually think
that they're hitting BP today oh wow
from like 3 30 to like fourth like
they're hitting BP on our field oh it's
like we do a lot of stuff with with the
Bengals
um
I wish that they were more open to doing
stuff with us well you can hear you can
help you guys post this too yeah yeah
when you're here to crack that mode yeah
they need to you know so maybe maybe but
maybe you got to take the initiative
maybe you got to just go do too much
maybe you got to go to more games and
show more support and maybe they'll tap
back in with you that's right whoever
the players relation guy is that there's
well we now now you got to do your part
in it he ain't you know I'm saying you
just got to go and no you're right you
know what and and bring them to you
you're right you know what I'm saying
because it'd be cool you hunter green
you here for the next six years that's
what I'm saying you're gonna be that
dude we got to be tapped in with the
other sports team tapped in with the
other sports teams because that's
important especially when you've been in
the community because y'all can do
things together 100 all right so I got
some fan questions uh from Instagram
first is how would Hunter try to get
mookie out yeah you don't have the
Facebook now you know how to we can't do
that we can't do that because
no actually yeah you're right yeah we
play you guys and so I don't want to do
that I'm gonna say that it's already
enough trying to hit a hundred
so uh yeah I don't know any tips on
throwing hard as hard as this is the
most common question yeah so I feel like
I I want I'm not answering for you but I
do have a thought on that okay like
things like that question is what
hurts not hurts like makes it hard for
me sometimes to go help people because I
do wanna
I do want to help people yeah but I
don't want to think want them to think
that I'm gonna make
yeah sure you know what I'm saying like
so do have you ever experienced that
like I can't really tell you how to
throw a hundred like I can just maybe
help your cleaning I mean yeah you're uh
yeah uh yeah your mechanics or whatever
yeah yeah for sure I mean I don't
I've never thought like okay I'm gonna
I'm gonna change this for or this person
is
this person's gonna hate me because
they're not throwing 100 you know miles
per hour and it's you know that'd be
wild right but
um yeah I mean it it is tough like like
you said like you're trying to make
somebody better but at the same time
like you know that one little tip or one
little thing isn't going to do that it's
years of you know dedication and
practice and
um and and work so and a lot of people
as you know aren't down to put their
work in you know so
um that's us looking from it looking at
it from our lens of doing like you know
the work that is so let's flip it in put
in varians how would you how would you
what would you say for that question
like is there any tips yeah
um I mean man doing
as much I love doing yoga and pilates
right now I do Pilates more than yoga
um do you do that time under two yeah
like we have a Pilates instructor
actually used to be with the Dodgers oh
nice but she's with us at all of our
home games then on the road she'll go on
some road trips which is dope so being
able to have access to her has been
great time under tension being able to
like hold poses
um and certain exercises for a long
amount of time or you know having
resistance and being able to hold it
building strength like that is super
important but being explosive is
possible like training as an infielder
being a pitcher but training as you know
a short size like as an athlete made me
that much better of a pitcher being able
to fill my position playing other sports
I'm assuming helped as well you know man
I didn't play other sports I wouldn't do
anything about that though because I
know oh I thought I could have sworn you
was a DN or something coming back in QB
my brother because I was trying to give
you the water
yeah I never my parents never put me
anything my pops played football but he
dealt with all the injuries okay didn't
want me to deal with like the back and
neck stuff but yeah just baseball so
what did you do to stay athletic then
I just I mean I was just I mean I just
trained as a trained it I don't know
like so that's a great question I never
you just said what'd you do to train as
a as an app I don't know I just you just
did just ran and my pops went my pops
went with the uh running coach when I
was like
Maybe
12 or 13 about to go into my freshman
year high school to get my running down
because I'm a size 15 shoe now but I was
like my age was always my shoe size like
it was just it was awkward like I was
just this little like baby giraffe
and uh trying to figure out like you
know how am I gonna grow into my body
you know how to have a good running form
so when I did grow into my body like I
didn't look funky you know and I picked
up speed and all that stuff so I think
that helped like being exposed that
early and yeah so you had so pops your
folks really really
yeah make sure you uh yeah they spent a
lot of money on making sure that I will
tell them thank you I'm sure you did
because just always tell them thank you
man it's a good parents you know who you
uh who you grew up around is who you're
going to be like and so your folks your
folks did it right so let's go to
another question who is the who's your
dream batter to face all like all time
foreign
I've been doing a lot better against
lefties this year so I would say uh I'd
say Griffey Griffey be able to fix it
yeah yeah that would be cool I wanna I
would I hope he watches this because I
wanna I wanna I'm gonna talk to him I
know you're gonna talk so much yeah he's
gonna talk so much you got to you know
yeah that was cool that was cool having
him I was saying like that that was
super super dope having him and he his
mental his mental side was well that's
what I learned from the most is the
mental
and and because like realistically he
can't tell me how to hit like him you
know what I'm saying like that's Ken
Griffey Jr I heard that about Barry
Bonds to like him trying to explain to
people like he'd just be like yeah just
like just turn on it yeah just turn on
and it's like and what you know for him
they probably did just turn on yeah you
know what I'm saying but for us like it
doesn't make sense yeah you know and so
um but I would I would like to see that
I would like to see that guy you know
whatever but either way it's going to be
entertaining yeah he's got that swing
it's beautiful
do you have a strikeout like a a thing
you do when you strike people out nah
man you know I haven't you know who's my
favorite so like strikeout celebration
is Luis Castillo you see his or he just
like it'd be great if you guys pulled up
Luis right now just he throws and he
like turns around and just like this
yeah he does the tiger the tiger was so
far he was with us I
being able to pitch with him last year a
little bit before he went over to
Seattle man it was so fun to watch
because it was just like it was
automatic it was so smooth like he knew
that he was going to strike somebody out
before he did it so he
yeah there was no hesitation just right
in front of him he just spins into like
he'll finish and then he'll spin on like
his his front toe and then just a
silence
I love watching it well you got to come
up with a thing I know you got a couple
we gotta we got to get you loosened up a
little bit though you in the big leagues
I think the toughest part is
I know I got to go out there inning
after
so like doing something wild and like
some subtle just some subtle you'll come
up with it'll hit you it'll hit you
something real quick it'll find me so we
got another uh we got another question
what are your plans after your MLB
do you have any that's a tough question
especially being so young if I'm blessed
to have the career that I want to have
I don't want to answer to nobody I just
want I want to post up and travel
I love food I love traveling
I love new experiences
I just want to be able to go do whatever
I want and not have to answer to anybody
and just enjoy my life with my family
and chill so what what's one of the best
restaurants you've been to
um
like do you not do you go to restaurants
when we're on the road oh yeah okay so
we're like yeah
like we're going okay so what's one of
the best restaurants
um
man
because I'm thinking like okay Ambiance
or like food or like everything
everything
I really liked SoDo Soto in Toronto
Toronto's got a lot of dope restaurants
yeah it was like a very mafioso like
small Italian
restaurant just like everybody knows
each other a little two-story like I had
a risotto that was like this big it was
really really good so so
there is a I cannot think of the name of
that Steakhouse in Toronto
is it in like a like blue blue something
or I'm not sure it's in like a castle or
it's like in a a house or a castle yeah
something like that but I don't remember
the name of it okay
golly okay what's another one what about
in uh
in Chicago have you been any restaurants
there that's one of my favorite cities
New York New York New York obviously I
like Chicago though more of the food
scene in Chicago
I don't know like why but it's just like
it feels more
Chicago feels a little bit more homey
because yep I don't know if it's just a
little it's smaller than New York you
know but it's still like feels like a
big city it's wild to think that's in
the midwest I know Chicago yeah you
think like the rest of it was like
Chicago yeah Chicago random uh a Linea I
really liked Linea dope I've been there
I've been there super super dope I went
last year I took Justin Dunn and I he's
another question uh we took our one of
our head trainers and our Pilates
instructor just as like a thank you like
end of the season it was like our last
Road Series and took them out and
enjoyed that man so that was cool trying
to do more like Michelin star
restaurants
okay so so
any every city you go to you try and hit
a restaurant yes if you can yeah yeah
okay so I'm trying to get better with
that man because like it's hard like but
it's just like eating and like gaining
weight like you know the food on the
plane yeah
I'm the opposite though I'll lose weight
because I just don't eat yeah it's hard
it's hard for me to eat so wrapping up
super dirt you're super dope dude I'm
super happy to see especially a brother
you personally have so much success
um you know especially in this city
which you you're bringing winning back
you're bringing everything that you need
to do shout out to your parents
um I do want to meet them one day and
for those who don't know where to cut
catch hunter green you can probably hear
soon you could probably catch him on a
stream
painting with a do-rag on because them
waves are fantastic
360 360 waves
oh
[Music]